of course you you hear this all the time
but uh
and you're allotted for your acting
ability one of the things that i find
most incredible about what you're able
to do is
you're one of the funniest performers
that i've seen and you're also
able to as we all know uh just nail
drama and i'm wondering what is your
secret weapon
what do you think is your secret weapon
in your
acting career what have you got what
have you got that
you can always rely on is there
something about your face that you think
helps you yeah i mean i i
i have that uh kind of uh resting face
that is
as scorn and anger and
and uh you know i mean it's just
yes well look of uh in consternation and
intensity oh yeah
yeah i don't think anybody has the
consternation phase that well
i i take that back because you had clint
eastwood oh my god
and harrison ford perhaps and
but i'm consternation in my resting face
look here
recipe no emotion no thinking of
anything
consternation right there and so
so i look i look that already
then you enter a real dilemma and boy it
just compounds
wow and people think that i'm i'm
actually thinking of something and i'm
like right now when i'm talking to you
i'm actually thinking of lunch
so you're not engaged in this interview
not at all you you haven't thought about
anything i've said you haven't even
listened to me
i did listen to you when i first got
here and you said hey good to see you
yeah and then after that you've been
checked out
you're such a good actor that you appear
to be engaged in this interview
but now you're telling us you're
somewhere else you're not even here at
this moment
i'm sorry said um let's let it go okay
you
um you're a bad man people need to know
that what well you know what i mean
when i say bad i mean just evil